Moin Leute, also ich dachte eigentlich wir können jetzt das neue Mikro ausprobieren
was ich mir mal bestellt habe um Technikvideos aufzunehmen.
Allerdings, vielleicht den noch dran, da hat man so einen Adapter gebraucht, aber ich habe keine Ahnung wo ich das hin habe.
Ich finde es nicht mehr, das ist natürlich jetzt auch eine kacke Kombi.
Ich habe jetzt den Adapter hier, aber ich finde das Mikrofon nicht.
Ich habe alles mögliche, ich habe hier alles schon durchwühlt hier, die Kiste mit den SD-Karten, die Kiste mit den Audio-Adaptern.
Aber irgendwie finde ich das Mikrofon nicht.
Das habe ich wahrscheinlich absichtlich an irgendeinen Platz gelegt wo ich es definitiv finde und der ist so offensichtlich, dass ich es nicht mehr finde.
Also Big Brain Play im Endeffekt.
Das kann doch nicht sein, wo habe ich das Mikrofon denn hin?
Wo würde ich das Mikrofon nach dem Stream hinlegen?
Ich meine wir haben es ausprobiert, das hat nicht funktioniert.
Ich würde das wahrscheinlich an den Anschluss vom Audio-Zeug wiederlegen, aber da liegt es nicht und ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, ich habe es wieder eingepackt.
Ich habe es wieder eingepackt.
Das heißt ich müsste doch irgendeine rote Kiste suchen.
Irgendwie, keine Ahnung. Irgendwie sind die nicht da.
Bildschirmarbeiter, 4 Monate, Dankeschön, POG.
Ich muss von Nacht ins Krankenhaus mit meiner Mutter, die ist auch noch da.
Ich fahre da aber erst nachher hin, ich habe Essen bestellt.
Das ist dann wahrscheinlich so, deswegen muss ich darauf achten im Hintergrund, ob das bimmelt oder so.
Ich habe Essen bestellt auf 13.15 Uhr, Dönerpide mit Pommes frites.
Pommes frites eigentlich nur für wenn es bestellt wird.
Deswegen mache ich jetzt einfach mal Strema, weil ich habe sonst eh gerade nichts großartiges zu tun.
Ergab mich jetzt das Mikro nicht für den Alter Max, wo hast du das Mikro hin, das kann doch nicht so weit weg sein.
So nicht.
Geht mir voll auf den Keks, ich wollte mal gucken wie die Quali jetzt ist, aber nope.
Der geht schon wieder ein bisschen besser, also der ging es gestern Nacht schon besser.
Das Problem ist halt, dass im Krankenhaus heute noch mal einer da ist.
Heute muss er noch irgendwie Zeugs nehmen und morgen ist dann halt keiner richtig da.
Das ist also möglichst wahrscheinlich, da kann die halt erst Montag heim.
Ja das ist also es ist glücklicherweise wohl jetzt nichts ganz Schlimmes gewesen.
Weil ich ja sagen muss, ich habe ja noch nie irgendwie mit dem Notruf zu tun gehabt.
Ich habe da noch nie, keine Ahnung, normalerweise machst du das ja auch nicht einfach so random um zu gucken wie ist das so, wenn man anruft.
Deswegen ich muss jetzt mal gucken, dass ich mein Handy irgendwie so platziere, dass ich sehe, falls das, ich mache es glaube ich mal laut.
Das schadet auf jeden Fall nichts, falls irgendwas ist.
Ich fälle das mal so hin, dass man was sieht.
Ich hoffe es gibt keine Audio-Dinger, gellte das noch früher?
Wo die ganzen Handys, wenn die zu nah am Mikrofon gelegen haben oder zu nah am Audio, dass die gemacht haben.
Tja, wo hast du das Rode-Mikrofon hin?
Das kann doch nicht so falsch sein.
Das ist heute, ja ja ich glaube das ist heute immer noch so, aber ich glaube die Dinger sünden sich oder ich weiß ja nicht was das ist, genau das was den Sound macht.
Das ist auch immer noch so, aber ich bilde mir an das war früher öfters.
Ja irgendwie das Rode-Mikrofon ist nicht auffindbar.
Ja und deswegen dachte ich mir so, ey, wenn ich jetzt eh hier rumstellze, bis ich dann, keine Ahnung, bis das Essen da ist und bis ich dann losfahre zu ins Krankenhaus, dann mache ich einfach mal Streben an.
Wir gucken irgendwie ein bisschen Zeug an.
Wenn du ein iPhone nimmst, dir die Kamera legst, die aufnimmt, hast du Störgeräusche.
Echt? Lustig, wüsste ich gar nicht.
Wubulul.
Ne, aber was ich sagen wollte ist, ey, da kriegste schon ein bisschen Schiss, wenn du so am Notruf anrufst, und die waren ja mega schnell da.
Angerufen und gesagt hier blablabla, ja hier Adresse und so, ob irgendwie was jetzt akut ist, naja nicht so richtig, zack.
Keine Ahnung, 5 Minuten oder so, jup am Start.
Ich konnte mir gerade mal noch eine ordentliche Jeans anziehen und einen Hemd anziehen.
Da war ich schon am Start.
Dann habe ich ihn aufgemacht, dann haben sie ein bisschen untersucht und dann haben sie dann halt eingepackt den Krankenwagen, dann habe ich alles zugemacht, sind im Krankenwagen ins Krankenhaus gefahren und dann hat das eigentlich gar nicht so lange gedauert.
Aber die haben halt relativ viel gemacht, ja, also gucken, dass auch nicht wirklich herzmäßig was Schlimmes ist und sonst was.
Und um, also um 23.30 Uhr ungefähr haben wir da angerufen und um, ich sag mal so um 5.30 Uhr oder so war ich wieder daheim, das war ganz toll.
Ja, ich kann mir da auch besseres vorstellen, zack, Alter.
Ja, mal gucken, ich fahre da nachher hin und mal gucken, was dann Sache ist.
Stell dir vor, das wäre die Bahn, ja, das wäre echt so ein Arsch, dann wäre bei vielen Leuten ein RIP, wenn das die Bahn wäre.
Deswegen Leute, ich habe jetzt eigentlich überhaupt keinen Plan, was wir machen, also ihr könnt mich irgendwelches Zeug fangen oder wir können uns irgendwelches Zeug fangen.
Na, mal gucken, ich wollte mal gerade schauen, ob es eine neue Sache gibt, neue Sache für den Staubsauger, nope.
Was sind da eigentlich so für Github-Projekte gerade voll angesagt?
Trending, zeig mal her, was gibt es noch auf Github, was all trendet?
USA Constitution, what?
Okay, das ist irgendein Kokona-Ding, was mich nicht interessiert.
Notebook for Scala, ich hörte kein Scala.
Eine neue Programmiersprache, also wie viele Programmiersprachen wollen die Leute eigentlich noch erfinden?
Was hilft bei Summen den Kopfhörern am PC? Gucken, dass ich einen anderen Anschluss anschließe, der nicht summt.
Okay, das ist komplett auf japanisch.
19.10.2020, ja, da hat er aber gut vor, ja.
Blorn, Programmiersprache, okay, was auch immer.
Kriegt übelste Sterne, aber kein Beispiel oder doch hier Sample.
Sample, Mist, Blorn.
Ygit, sehr hässlich.
Naja, also was allgemein hilft ist, wenn du dazwischen ein Stückchen Glasfaser hast, ja.
Also wenn du einen Tostling-Ausgang hast und du stöpselst da irgendwie dann ein Audiointerface dran und machst da den Kopfhörer dran,
dann hast du wahrscheinlich auch kein Gebrumme, oder du guckst, dass irgendwie alles am gleichen Stecker hängt, da kommt das ja auch manchmal her.
Ich hab das hier bei mir auch, wenn ich beispielsweise,
wenn ich mein Audiointerface in den anderen Rechner stecke für Power und den links in die Steckdose stecke, dann summt das auch.
Und wenn das ansonsten weiter summt, dann hat vielleicht der Kopfhörer irgendeinen Schaden.
Was immer ganz gut ist, wenn man die Kopfhörer am Smartphone anschließt und guckt, weil am Smartphone da hast du halt keine Sache mit irgendwie am falschen Stromstecker angeschlossen,
das ist halt halt in der Luft und in der Luft dann wenig.
Dual mit dem Friseur, naja, der hat keinen Bock auf YouTube.
Das hätt ich das ja schon gemacht.
Sonst hätt ich das ja schon gemacht, an mir liegt das ja nicht.
Ich weiß mir nix auf. Ich muss mal gucken, wie ich mein Handy hinleg, dass ich das bald sehe.
Ladegerät drunter machen oder so.
Ihr glaubt's nicht, ich hab grad vorhin noch ein Toastbrot gemacht.
Ich hab ne Marmelade unten, die heißt Feuchter Traumaprikose.
Da hab ich mir auch gedacht, was ist das für ein knackter Name.
Wir haben keine Framedrops, was auch immer das gestern gewesen ist.
Kann man auf Twitch mit mehr als 60Hz streamen?
Ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung, hab ich das schon mal ausprobiert.
144 FPS Streaming.
Was trendet denn noch so?
Java trendet? Nee, ach nee, irgendwelche Algorithmus Package für Java.
Das was auf GitHub trendet ist irgendwie ziemlich langweilig gerade.
Machine Learning, Google Research, was auch immer die da researchen.
Javascript-Frameworks ist ja eh das krasseste.
Es spawnen am Tag 50 neue Javascript-Frameworks und alle sind irgendwie beliebt.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das überhaupt funktioniert.
Okay, ich muss doch den Sound vom Handy wieder ausmachen, weil jetzt jeder Twitter-Nachricht und alles, was mich irgendwie notif-notif-notif-notif-hatet, macht jetzt blubblubblub.
Weil ich ja sagen muss, ich finde den Standard-Apple-Notification-Ton noch am angenehmsten.
Kennt ihr noch diesen, was war das Samsung, wo es dann immer gemacht hat?
War das Samsung?
Das ging mir auf den Zack, vor allem zu der Zeit, wo alle angefangen haben, sich Samsung-Telefone zu kaufen.
Oder war das WhatsApp? Nee, das war Samsung.
Aber wahrscheinlich war das bei WhatsApp auf Samsung-Telefon auch so.
Zumindest die Zeiten, wo dann alle angefangen haben, irgendwie auch mehr Android, wo es dann auch manche gecheckt haben, dass so ein Android-Telefon auch seine Vorteile hat.
Und hauptsächlich, dass dann Samsung gekauft haben, da war es so, dass du teilweise im Zug gesessen hast.
Du hast von allen Seiten gehört, weil die Leute ja irgendwie so unkreativ sind und immer den Standard auch drin lassen.
Vor allem kann er auch noch laut machen. Man sitzt dann da und der nächste.
Logstash. Oh, das gibt es immer noch. Das ist eigentlich ganz nice.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass Logstash-Ruby. Ach, das ist Go oder Java oder so.
Das klingt auch ein bisschen Java. Ah, JRuby ist das. JRuby. Okay, das ist Java.
Kubernetes Basic Learning. Okay, das ist für alle, die den Kubernetes-Hype-Train aufspringen wollen.
Also, wenn ihr einen Job sucht, Leute, irgendwie im Umfeld, wo in der Stellenanzei...
Aber wir können... Stellanzeigen gleich nochmal. Wenn ihr irgendwas in irgendeiner Stellenanzeige von Cloud seht,
dann droppt einfach mal Kubernetes, wenn ihr euch da einen guten Eindruck machen wollt.
Ihr sagt einfach Azure, Kubernetes und Docker. Es ist egal, ob ihr das in irgendeiner sinnvollen Zusammenhängen der Art und Weise sagt,
bei der ersten Durchsicht, weil wenn es ein großer Laden ist, da gucken sich irgendwelche Personalleute an, die keinen Plan haben.
Dann sagt ihr einfach mal kurz Kubernetes, Azure, Docker und dann sagt ihr,
Hallo, Alter, Cloud, unser neuer Cloud-Architekt. Dann freuen sie sich alle, wenn sie das gehört haben.
Natürlich, am Ende müsst ihr dann noch ein bisschen wissen, wovon ihr sprecht. Das wäre ein bisschen blöd.
Richtig Pepegas, die ihr Handy nicht auf lautlos haben außer Haus. Ja, aber richtig.
Huge Pepega.
Sound eigentlich laut.
Ja, ist laut genug.
Weil ich habe den Sound bei mir ein bisschen runtergedreht. Bei euch müsste es halbwegs normal sein, dass ich höre, wenn der Dönermann klingelt.
Vielleicht gibt es Döner, Pide oder Pide, nicht Döner, mit Döner.
So was da gibt es gleich.
Aus in der Nichtung.
Warum ist das eigentlich so ein Schiff?
Es wird doch auch ohne Schiff schmecken und als Schiff macht es doch noch viel mehr Aufwand.
Nee, nicht 12 Uhr, 13 Uhr. Ich habe auf 13 Uhr nur 15 Uhr bestellt.
Aber warum macht man da so ein Schiff? Das ist doch viel aufwendiger.
Könnte ich es nicht einfach glatt machen und einfach zwei Euro weniger nehmen?
Big Brain.
Wahrscheinlich kann man Döner bestellen.
Alles bestellen.
Du kannst sogar mittlerweile bei Lidl Edeka Rewe irgendwie einen Joghurt bestellen oder so.
Oder sogar, ich glaube sogar bei Edeka ging das, bei Edeka kannst du sogar auf Schnitzel und sowas bestellen.
Bei Edeka irgendwo kannst du Schnitzel bestellen.
Ach nee, das war dieser Edeka Spawn.
Das ist Edeka, heißt aber nicht Edeka, weil die Leute irgendwie denken, das klingt doof, wenn da Edeka drauf steht.
Hier.
Bam.
Ohne Schnitzel oder so.
Also man kann mittlerweile echt schon alles online bestellen.
Leider nicht bei Amazon, aber bei Lebensmittel verstehe ich, dass es bei Amazon nicht so toll ist.
Da haben natürlich irgendwelche traditionellen Supermärkte schon ein bisschen Vorteile mit ihrer Rewe.
Rewe liefert alles auch Schnitzel. Okay, da muss ich da mal gucken.
Rewe Shop.
Hat er die Story schon durch? Nee.
Ich weiß noch nicht, ob ich die Story heute Abend noch weiter spiele.
Also ich spiele die Story auf jeden Fall weiter, aber ich weiß noch nicht, ob ich heute Abend noch mal Zeit habe, Story zu spielen.
Muss ich mal gucken.
Aber heute oder morgen spielen wir die Story.
Also gucken wir mal, ob es beim Rewe Schnitzel gibt.
Gucken wir mal, ob es in Frankfurt beim Rewe Schnitzel gibt.
Nach Hause.
Okay, Schnitzel.
Ach, das sind die eingeschwein...
Okay, Tiefkühlschnitzel oder sowas.
Ich weiß nicht.
Bio-Schweine-Schnitzel, 500 Gramm.
Also einen Vorteil hat es beim Edeka schon, wobei das haben die beim Rewe eigentlich auch, dass die halt so eine Theke haben.
Aber ansonsten.
Pomlakser, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön.
Pomlakser, erinnert mich irgendwie an Benlakser.
Falls das noch jemand kennt.
Der Tier-Tier-Ernährungsexperte oder sowas.
Ich weiß nicht mal, wie das geht.
Der hat irgendwie seinen Channel verkauft.
Was mit dem passiert? Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Der hat seinen Channel verkauft.
Der ist erstmal in großem Formel.
Der sieht eigentlich auch mit Teppich verlegen so gut aus.
Okay, was ist denn noch bei GitHub gerade beliebt?
Mobi.
Also übrigens GitHub.
Also wenn man sich die Projekte anguckt, was voll abgeht, ist alles mögliche in JavaScript und irgendwie auch in Go.
Und in letzter Zeit tatsächlich auch saumäßig viel in.NET.
Wobei wir jetzt hier gerade nichts haben.
Was ist das?
Container.
Diese Container-Geschichte, das ist seit Jahren schon ziemlich hype.
Aber ich sag mal, es ist das letzte Jahr über.
Dieses Jahr und Ende letzten Jahres, da wird die übertreiben, das die Leute.
Die übertreiben das maßlos.
Ich will nicht wissen, wie viele Leute mittlerweile nicht mal mehr, keine Ahnung, einen IP-Calculator bei sich installieren lokal, wenn der nicht im Docker-Container läuft.
Das ist also die Leute übertreiben es heute schon ein bisschen.
Man muss auch nicht, wenn man aus seinem Linux einen Web-Server laufen lassen will, wenn ich den irgendwie in Nginx oder so laufen lassen will,
dann muss ich das nicht im Docker-Container machen.
Das muss nicht sein.
Man muss es nicht übertreiben.
Man muss sich alles in den Docker-Container stecken.
Alles in den Docker-Container pfeifen.
Ja und sich danach beschweren, wenn es Probleme gibt, das Ding zu back-upen und sonst was.
Und hoch, das ist ja gar kein klassisches Linux mit Pfeilsystem drunter.
Also es ist schon ein bisschen übertrieben teilweise.
Übrigens, das was ich letztens im...
Nein, nein, nein.
Das was ich letztens vorgeschlagen habe im Video zu VPN, das war ja das hier.
Das hat auch ziemlich viele Bewertungen.
Das ist ja im Prinzip nur, in Anführungsstrichen, nur irgendwie so ein bisschen Installer-Scripts.
Da habe ich überlegt, weil ich habe das noch nie installiert.
Ich kenne das nur aus einem Webcast und dass das immer gelobt wird irgendwie.
Das müssen wir mal im Stream installieren, ob das damit wirklich so easy ist, sich einen VPN-Server auf einem Raspberry oder so zu installieren.
Oder auf einem...
Wir müssen das in Azure installieren, fällt mir gerade ein.
Weil ich habe da noch Azure-Guthaben.
Mal ausprobieren.
Twitch-Soundboard im Container, oder OBS im Container.
OBS im Container, also OBS im Container würde sogar funktionieren.
Ich glaube sogar, OBS gibt es fertig als Snap.
Das ist die Ubuntu-Container-Geschichte.
Gibt es fertig als Snap.
Also OBS-Docker ist wahrscheinlich kein großartiges Problem.
Ich meine, warum ist die Frage?
Ganz ehrlich, warum?
Warum, warum, warum OBS in Docker?
Für mich ergibt es keinen Sinn ehrlich gesagt.
Außer BigBrain, weil alles in Docker.
Aber ich sehe keinen Sinn ehrlich gesagt drin, dass man OBS in Docker laufen lässt.
Warum nicht ist die Frage.
Vielleicht Zugriff brauchst du Hardware und kein Bock hast, jedes Mal das irgendwie durchzureichen oder reinzufuddeln in Docker.
Vielleicht willst du das Ding Remote steuern und hast keinen Bock auf irgendwelche umständlichen Dinger, dass du da von anderen Rechnern drauf zugreifen kannst.
Also ich sehe da schon ein paar Punkte, warum OBS in einem Container jetzt nicht so der Wahnsinn ist.
Ich meine, machen kannst du das alles.
Es ist nicht so, dass man das nicht konfigurieren könnte.
Man kann ja auch X ohne Probleme in einem Container verwenden, wenn man das File weiterreicht.
Das geht, das ist kein Ding.
Aber warum man das will, weiß ich nicht.
Ich meine, vor allem OBS installiert und gut ist, das muss nicht alles in Docker laufen.
Ppega Board im Container.
Das Ppega Board, das wird wahrscheinlich sogar auf einem Staubsauger laufen.
Das haben wir letztens ausprobiert mit dem Versandtracker.
Der lief ja auf einem Staubsauger.
Was wäre ein Vorteil eines Containers gegenüber einer VM?
Eine VM braucht auf jeden Fall deutlich mehr Ressourcen, auch wenn es jetzt nicht so ist,
dass eine VM heutzutage wahnsinnig auf CPU oder RAM oder sonst was schlagen würde.
Also vor allem nicht Linux, Windows oder ein anderes Thema.
Windows braucht natürlich ordentlich RAM.
Aber ein Container ist halt deutlich leichtgewichtiger.
Allerdings muss man halt sagen, ein Container ist halt eigentlich überhaupt nicht vergleichbar so richtig mit einer VM.
Eine VM ist halt eine Software, die quasi Low Level einmal Hardware emuliert.
Und halt, dass das Betriebssystem in der VM denkt, es hat andere Hardware als der Host.
Und on the fly für die CPU irgendwelche Sachen umschreibt, dass die halt in der VM ordentlich funktionieren.
Also sprich, eine VM hat deutlich mehr drum herum.
Und dementsprechend ist eine VM auch viel viel besser isoliert.
Ein Container, das Wort an sich ist ein bisschen doof, weil es viele Leute an eine VM irgendwie erst mal erinnert.
Aber eigentlich, wenn man sich das mal überlegt, trifft es das ganz gut.
Ein Container ist eigentlich nichts anderes, wie, also mal angenommen du startest bei dir auf dem Rechner OBS.
Und du startest in einem Docker Container OBS.
Das ist eigentlich kein großer Unterschied.
Das sind beides Prozesse, die gestartet werden und dann laufen.
Da ist so richtig kein großer Unterschied zwischen dem containerisierten Prozess und dem normalen Prozess.
Außer, dass halt ein paar Sachen für den containerisierten Prozess in eigene Namespaces gepackt wurden.
Also der sieht dann beispielsweise sein eigenes Netzwerk und der sieht dann irgendwie teilweise, gibt es ja noch doch, eigene Hostname und sowas in der Richtung.
Aber es ist immer noch ein stinknormaler Prozess, der auf deinem Host läuft.
Das ist ja auch ein Unterschied, was du in der VM hast.
In der VM läuft ein vollständiges Betriebssystem, auf dem dann dein Zeug läuft, was du laufen lassen willst.
Im Container ist das nicht so, im Container benutzt du alles von deinem Host.
Das heißt, es ist beispielsweise richtig blöde, wenn man in Containern Sachen benutzen möchte, die Kernel-Module brauchen.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Dann muss man natürlich, man kann das Kernel-Module auf dem Host laden, das funktioniert.
Aber spätestens, wenn du zwei Container hast, die da unterschiedliche Sachen machen wollen und so.
Also es ist halt immer noch das gleiche Betriebssystem, wenn du ein Container startest, im Vergleich zur VM.
VM ist ein komplett eigenes Betriebssystem drunter, eigener Kernel, sonst was, kannst alles machen, was du willst.
Und Container ist halt im Prinzip nur ein Prozess, der ein bisschen mehr Sandbox drumherum hat.
Ich glaube, das hat man ja verstanden, oder?
So, nutzt du Docker in Windows? Nee. Und Docker in Windows ist auch kein Docker, sondern es ist Hyper-V.
Wobei, das stimmt nicht, das habe ich selbst Mist erzählt.
Docker ist ja selbst auch unter Linux gar nicht die Container-Geschichte.
Docker ist quasi nur das Frontend dafür.
Das heißt also quasi, sagen wir mal ganz, ganz billig gesagt, die Kommando-Zeilen-Tools.
Das macht noch viel mehr.
Also Docker ist im Prinzip ja nur das User-Interface für LXC.
Alles, was ihr irgendwie hört, was mit Container und Linux zu tun hat, das ist alles LXC.
Kubernetes auch, alles.
Weil LXC und Cnames und Namespaces, das ist das, was im Linux-Container drin ist und für Container verwendet wird.
Das verwenden alle.
Egal, ob es Kubernetes ist, Docker, LXD oder so, es ist egal.
Das ist alles das Gleiche unter der Haube.
Da ist kein Unterschied.
Nur das Frontend ist quasi anders.
Linux-Container, es gibt nur eine Art von Linux-Container.
Okay, es gab früher noch mal was ganz Altes, habe ich sogar vergessen, wie es heißt.
Aber mittlerweile ist das alles, wie gesagt, LXC und Cnames, Namespaces.
Das alles ist das Gleiche.
Überhaupt kein Unterschied.
Dementsprechend verwendest du natürlich unter Windows tatsächlich Docker, weil es Docker,
ich meine nur, dass das Frontend quasi ist, was du zum Bedienen verwendest.
Und unter der Haube ist halt unter Linux LXC bzw. Linux-Container, wofür LXC übrigens auch steht.
Und unter Windows ist es Hyper-V.
Und KS.
Aber nee, benutze ich unter Windows nicht.
Was hältst du von der Windows-Sandbox?
Keine schlechte Idee.
Wir haben es hier letztens mal versucht zu starten irgendwo.
Nee, jetzt haben wir in der VM versucht.
Warum nicht?
Ist doch ganz gut, dass die noch mal in Windows mitliefern, was man verwenden kann,
wo man auf irgendwelche komischen Seiten muss.
Allerdings, ganz ehrlich, wenn ich auf Seiten möchte, wo ich mir nicht so ganz sicher bin,
dass die Seiten ordentlich sind, also dass die Seiten nix drauf haben,
dann verwende ich einfach eine VM mit Linux, weil dann hast du die wenigsten Probleme,
die einfach Linux-VM starten und Ruhe ist.
Woher kommt eigentlich MonkaS?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Mikrotik.
HiChat.
QtChat.
Der Bildschirmarbeiter sagt, ich brauche für meinen Proxmox-Server noch ein VPN.
Da müsste ich beispielsweise das Kernelmonoot auf dem Host laden,
wenn ich den WireGun-VPN-LXC-Container habe.
Richtig. Ja, das ist ein schönes Beispiel für, wie gesagt,
alles, was Panel-Module oder so braucht, ist in Containern immer so eine Sache.
Ist nicht so, dass es geht.
Das ist so die typische Linux-Geschichte.
Irgendwie geht fast alles, fast alles.
Das Einzige, was unter Linux irgendwie prinzipiell nicht funktionieren scheint,
ist, gescheite Musik-, Audio-, Video-Software zu entwickeln.
Dass es geht, sieht man an 3D-Geschichten wie Plender.
Es gibt ein paar Video-Shint-Programme, die gehen in die richtige Richtung.
Aber Bildbearbeitung, also klassische Pixel-Bildbearbeitung,
halt unter Linux, da kann keiner mit GIMP an.
Von Photoshop keine Ahnung, aber es gibt nichts Vergleichbares
wie Affinity Designer oder Affinity Photo unter Linux.
Das gibt es doch einfach nicht.
Kreative Sachen ist halt unter Linux blöd, da kriegen sie es auch nicht gebacken.
Ich glaube, das liegt gar nicht daran, dass es keine fähigen Leute gibt,
sondern die Sache ist die, dass hinter solcher Software mehr steckt,
als ein paar Leute, die neisse Technik programmieren wollen.
Sondern da steckt halt eine Firma dahinter, die halt auch Geld damit verdienen will.
Und manchmal ist es auch gar nicht verkehrt für die Benutzbarkeit von Software.
Weil eins muss man sagen, also...
Oh Mist, ich hab meine...
Fuck, ich kann meine Linux-VM nicht aufmachen.
Ich hab meine Linux-VM für Cod, sonst hätt ich euch mal was gezeigt.
Ich hab meine Linux-VM für Cod, dass ich 130 GB Platz habe,
hab ich meine Linux-VM vom Stream mal temporär auf der externer Platte geschoben,
die ich jetzt hier nicht mounten kann, weil ich den Key nur auf meinem anderen Account hab.
Hätt ich euch mal kurz was gezeigt.
Meinst du zwei verschiedene VPN-Verbindungen?
Eine auf Filmhost und eine auf mögliche Anonymität.
Wenn wir nach außen hin, ist das ja genau das gleiche.
Morphoys 420, zwei Monate, BigBrain, HiIQ, Sub, Dankeschön.
Der Lukas, X9, 8, X, Bridge Prime, POG.
Das Video ist relativ erfolgreich.
Ich hab übrigens gar nicht mit gerechnet, dass da so viele Leute interessiert.
Wann? Wie viele drei Comments?
Das ist doch so und so.
Durchschnitt, Überdurchschnitt.
Für so ein Thema hat das auch demnächst heute irgendwie über 20K.
So was hier interessiert die Leute natürlich mehr.
Oder so was interessiert die Leute auch mehr.
Oder Modern Warfare geht höher, interessiert die Leute auch mehr.
Krita ist, wenn du malen willst, ganz gut.
Aber das, was ich beispielsweise für die Thumbnail-Geschichte mit Affinity Designer und Brutto mache,
sowas gibt es unter Linux nicht wirklich.
Wo du einfach dir mal schön so eine Mischung aus Bildbearbeitung, Layout, transformieren und so.
Servus Max, wie findest du das neue Cod? Hab AW, World War 2, World War 4 ausgelassen, jetzt wieder angefangen, aber irgendwo bin ich scheinbar alt geworden.
Ne, mach dir nichts draus, das liegt an dem Cod.
Das kriegt jeder auf den Sack.
Das kriegt jeder auf den Sack, weil du halt gegen ultra gute Leute gematcht wirst im Verhältnis zu dir.
Geht jedem so, jeder.
Die einzigen Leute, die richtig krasse Gameplays zeigen, sind entweder Pros, die quasi ihre ersten Matches filmen
und dann noch nicht richtig gematcht werden, oder Leute, die Reverse boosten.
Oder mal einer, der halt gut ist und mal Glück hat, dass ein Gameplay von 40 gut ist.
Hast du schon mal Nextcloud verwendet? Ja.
Ach hab ich jetzt, aber hab ich drauf, hab ich drauf, ja.
Verwend ich auch.
Was, Veracrypt? Veracrypt hab ich.
Jaja, ist Veracrypt, genau.
Die Frage ist, warum hast du nur eine Platte im PC?
Jo, warum? Warum nicht?
Für Gameplays und so hab ich noch ne Magnetfestplatte.
Das ist ne NVMe SSD.
Ich hab hier übrigens schon seit über nem Monat ne 1TB NVMe liegen, die ich einbauen wollte.
Hier, hier liegt sie.
720, 970 Evo. Wollte ich schon einbauen.
Größe? Welche Größe hat die?
1TB. Ich weiß immer noch nicht, warum ich nicht eingebaut hab.
Faul.
Evo Plus oder Normal? Da steht kein Plus drauf, also denk ich mal Normal.
Wo ist denn der Unterschied überhaupt zwischen Evo und Evo Plus?
Stimmt es, dass COD 174 GB benötigt? Nein.
Stimmt nicht.
Es braucht 130.
Das ist jetzt kein Witz.
Es braucht 130. Guck.
Zeig ich dir.
Oh sorry, sorry.
113 sind es jetzt nur, aber der Download war 129.
Das braucht nur 113 GB.
Ja das ist doch nix. Das war ein Schnapper, das ist doch quasi geschenkt.
113 GB, easy.
Plus ist noch schneller als Evo. Ich glaube nicht, dass ich mit meiner SSD irgendwie Performance Probleme wegen der Übertragungsrate kriege.
Die Dinger sind eh schon so schnell. Und ganz ehrlich, ob ich jetzt, keine Ahnung, 600 MB die Sekunde oder 800 MB die Sekunde oder 2000 MB die Sekunde übertrage, ist normalerweise ziemlich wurscht.
Und ob die Zugriffszeit jetzt ein paar Nanosekunden sind oder zwei Nanosekunden oder vier oder was auch immer, ich weiß gar nicht, was die Zugriffszeit von der normalen SSD heute ist.
Das macht es wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht so fett.
Heftiges Gekämpfe, wie im neuen Call hast du noch nie gesehen, sagt Wraith. Ja so ging es mir in der Beta auch. Ich glaube, ganz ehrlich Leute, ich glaube, das aktuelle Call of Duty, das musst du mit zwei, drei Leuten spielen.
Dass du dich absprechen kannst, wer welche Ecke hält.
Das Ecken halten, campen ist noch schlimmer als in CS, weil in CS ist es ja selten so, dass du auf eine Ecke guckst für drei Minuten.
Also in CS guckst du zwar hier rum und du bleibst halt vielleicht auch mal stehen und wartest, je nachdem wie das auf der Map ist.
Aber normalerweise ist es in CS eher so, dass du dann ausschließt, wo Gegner sind.
Ihr seht das ja auch in irgendwelchen Pro-Matches in CS, im seltensten Fall stehen die wirklich da und gucken drei Minuten auf eine Ecke.
Und in CS ist das kein Problem, da stehst du auch da und guckst drei Minuten auf eine Ecke, wenn du kurz vor dem Killstrick bist, das juckt nicht überhaupt mit.
Und ja, die Maps, ich habe gestern Abend ja noch ein bisschen im Stream geguckt.
Ich habe beispielsweise mal bei Seagull reingeguckt. Ich meine, das ist kein Kotpro, aber da ist generell in allem, was FPS-mäßig ist, immer instant ziemlich gut, weil er halt ziemlich gut ist.
Also Seagull-Stream kann man immer sehr schön gucken, wenn ein Spiel neu rauskommt und er spielt das, da kann man immer schön sehen, wenn man selbst an sich zweifelt und sagt, alter du sucks so krass.
Wenn man sich Seagull anguckt und das Spiel ist neu, das geht immer nur ganz gut bei neuen Spielen, da kann man richtig gut die Performance einschätzen von, jemand ist richtig gut in dem Game für den aktuellen Zeitpunkt,
weil das ist er immer in den Spielen, wenn die neu raus sind, weil die anderen auch keinen Vorsprung hatten.
Und man kann das mit sich selbst vergleichen. Und wenn er auch immer auf den Sack kriegt die ganze Zeit, dann weißt du, das liegt nicht an dir.
Ich habe gehört, Doktor Disrespect ist gestern halb eskaliert mal wieder im Stream, der war übelst getiltet.
Die Maps sind halt, was ich gesehen habe, ich habe ja noch selbst nicht gespielt, ich musste ja gestern Jodaufnahme fahren, ist ja nicht so, dass ich da jetzt wahnsinnig geil drauf gewesen bin.
Leute, ich muss mal kurz in die Mails gucken, ob ich auch wirklich jetzt Essen bestellt habe oder ob ich nur den Bestellvorgang angefangen habe und dann abgebrochen habe, das wäre nämlich dumm.
Bestätigung Ihrer Zahlung an TakeAway.com, okay. Nice. Da, da sind alle dran.
Oh, Asus möchte mich einladen, habe ich gerade per Mail gesehen. Ich finde das interessant, ne. Seitdem ich wieder aktiv bin auf YouTube, kriege ich sau viele Anfragen und Einladungen.
Also was lädt mich denn Asus ein? Zeig mal her.
Erst mal gucken, ob sie irgendwie darauf Wert legen, dass das vertrauenswürdig ist. Also, was möchte mich denn Asus einladen? Zu einem exklusiven Event von Republic of Gamers. Yeah.
Endlich mal wieder rote RGBs. Rote RGB-Beleuchtung. Wobei das Zeug, also eins kann man ja nicht sagen, die haben zwar RGB-Beleuchtung und haben auch so die krasse Gamer-Optik, aber das Zeug ist schon okay.
Das mag zwar jetzt nicht meine Wahl sein, weil ich eher darauf gucke, dass das preisleistungsmäßig immer gut ist und ich brauche kein Mainboard mit RGB oder kein Mainboard, was irgendwie super stylische Kühler hat.
Ich meine, die richtig wichtigen Sachen, was Performance angeht und was man alles anschließen kann, kommt heute eh darauf an, was für eine CPU ist.
Was ist in deinem China Bookmark? Aliexpress verlinkte Sachen. Also, was haben sie denn noch hier? Zeig mal. Dann erzähle ich mal was zum neuen Code. Was haben sie denn hier?
In Köln, okay. 12-13. 45. Produktpräsentation, okay. Das ist Anpreisung. Danach gibt es eine Stunde Mittagessen. Danach gibt es FAQ, Interviews und Challenges.
Oh Gott, das klingt mir schon viel zu sozial alles. Danach ist Abendessen. Okay, es wird Anreise, Abreise, Verpflegung und Unterkunft in einem 4-Sterne-Hotel zur Erstattung, Reisekosten, bla bla bla.
Okay. Und man kriegt ein Hardware-Paket. Und man kriegt Mittag- und Abendessen. Okay, das ist natürlich eindeutig eine Verkaufsveranstaltung. Aber anderes kann das nicht sein.
Also, wenn da wirklich alles übernommen wird und dann am Ende kriegst du noch ein Hardware-Paket, das ist eindeutig eine Verkaufsveranstaltung. Aber auf der anderen Seite, warum nicht?
Ach ja, das ist, jawoll, Blumix, das ist eine gute Idee, wie du da sagst.
Auf geht's, hin da. Was wird denn da gezeigt? Keine Ahnung, Hardware steht nicht da. Wahrscheinlich wollen sie nicht, also es könnte ja sein, dass es etwas Neues ist oder etwas, was nicht so öffentlich ist, dass sie dann es nicht reinschreiben wollen, dass gleich irgendjemand zu ihnen in die News-Seite geht und sagt, ach guck mal, die haben was Neues.
Hardware, Hardware wird da gezeigt. Ich gehe davon aus, sie zeigen neue Mainboards für das neue Intel-Zeug.
Die werden wahrscheinlich, also die üblichen Rocksachen, wahrscheinlich noch einen neuen Monitor oder irgendwie neue, tolle Beleuchtung oder was. Was haben die eigentlich alles so? Also so Rocks. Notebooks, Headsets, Grafikkarten.
Was ist denn eine, was ist denn eine 2080 TI? Was ist denn das?
Was Neues? Ach nee, ich glaube, die haben sich auch noch verschrieben, oder? Ich glaube, die haben sich noch verschrieben, oder? Ist das wirklich was Neues?
Nee, okay, okay. Ich dachte schon, Nvidia hat mal wieder was Neues. Ja, die haben ja, die haben ein Phone. Die haben tatsächlich ein Phone.
Das ist, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob das das Asus Phone ist oder das Razer Phone, was den Lüfter hatte. Ich glaube, Phone 10. Ja, genau.
Also wer schon immer mal ein Smartphone mit Lüfter haben möchte, der liegt da richtig. Ey, und das ist jetzt kein manipuliertes Bild oder so. Das ist von der Rockseite. Also das ist echt so.
Gag weh. Ich habe schon immer mal, ach ja, ein Fortanat, ich glaube, HDMI, Mini HDMI oder so, und Audio ist auch am Lüfter dran.
Ja, ganz ehrlich, Schnee, Flöckchen, Flockchen, da würde ich auch eine Switch bevorzugen.
Naja, aber so Zeugs wird dann halt wahrscheinlich vorgestellt. Das habe ich vergessen. Wann war das nochmal? November irgendwann? Ich habe es schon wieder vergessen.
Also wenn es an einem Tag ist, wo mein Urlaub schon anfängt, weil ihr wisst ja, ich habe wieder kompletten Dezember-Urlaub bzw. auch schon ein Ticken davor, war ich ja jedes Jahr so.
Ah nee, das ist die Woche bevor ich Urlaub habe. Aber es ist morgen. Nach Köln komme ich gut hin. Köln, Frankfurt dauert 55 Minuten oder so. Das ist schnell, vielleicht gehe ich nicht.
Aber wisst ihr, eine Sache lässt mich da noch zweifeln, ob ich hingehe. Ach, es sind gerade Bauarbeiten am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof. Stimmt, kann man mich überhaupt vergleichen, die bauen ja gerade um.
Ja, eine Stunde dauert es. Es ist glaube ich sogar noch manchmal ein Ticken schneller. Kannst du da nicht hinfliegen? Nee, hinfliegen dauert länger.
Als ob, na klar dauert es länger. Der Frankfurter Flughafen ist komplett in die andere Richtung. Du musst 30 Minuten vorher da sein, dann fliegst du eine Stunde. Du fliegst in der Regel in Deutschland immer eine Stunde.
Und dann musst du zum Flughafen. Ich weiß gar nicht, was ist der nächste Flughafen. Was ist der nächste Flughafen? Hat Köln überhaupt einen Flughafen? Keine Ahnung. Dann musst du von da an dort hinfahren, wo das Event ist. Du bist viel länger unterwegs als wenn du dich in den Zug steigst. Düsseldorf. Elite Style HD.
Also wahrscheinlich bin ich mit dem Zug eineinhalb Stunden unterwegs von mir, inklusive hin zum Bahnhof und zurück. Und mit dem Flieger braucht es wahrscheinlich dreieinhalb Stunden. Oder vier. Bis ich da bin.
Also das lohnt, na sagen wir mal drei. Drei. Drei, dreieinhalb Stunden. Das lohnt sich nicht. Ja, Bildschirmarbeit. Das lohnt sich nicht. Also es gibt eine Sache, warum ich gerade dran zweifel, ob ich da hingehe. Also grundsätzlich.
Und zwar, das ist kein Event, wo einfach neue Hardware vorgestellt wird. Das ist ein, schreiben sie im Titel, ein Influencer Event. Das heißt, das sind ganzen nervigen Leute am Start, mit denen ich eigentlich nichts zu tun habe.
Deswegen gehe ich da nicht hin. Oh, es gibt auch noch einen Punkt. Und was erwarten wir von dir? Okay. Da muss ich mal gucken. Da muss ich mal gucken, was von mir erwartet wird. Wahrscheinlich, ich will ja eh schon nicht hin. Und wahrscheinlich, wenn ich das jetzt lese, würde ich da noch weniger hin.
Mindestens, okay, also man soll, okay, man soll auf Social Media einen Post machen, dass man zum Event fährt und seine Community fragen, ob man, ob sie Fragen an ASUS haben. Ja, okay, das kann man machen.
Mindestens einen Bild- oder Videobeitrag. Okay, da hast du wohl ein Video noch. Livestream vom Event. Okay. Ach so, oder deine gefilmten Eindrücke in einem Video. Nee. Nee, auch ganz ehrlich.
Ich habe ja eh schon keinen Bock drauf. Und unter den Bedingungen, das wäre ja, da müsste ich ja, da würde ich ja schon irgendwo hinfahren, wo ich eh keinen richtigen Bock drauf habe. Und dann müsste ich da noch Videos gezwungener Wasen drüber machen, über Sachen, die mich wahrscheinlich nur so am Rande jucken. Nee. Nee, das muss nicht sein.
Frage, warum ist euer Stuff so teuer? Weil RGB-Beleuchtung Geld kostet. Im Video sagst du, dass du keinen Bock hattest, aber gratis Essen gab. Nee, sowas mache ich nicht. Ich sage dir dann immer vorher, wenn ich keinen Bock habe.
Es sei denn, die Produkte sind wirklich richtig kacke. Oh und, dann habe ich noch was. Und zwar, habe ich gerade gesehen, ich habe mal wieder ein Angebot zu Wargaming World of Tanks. Die sind sehr umtriebig, muss man sagen.
Das gibt es öfters. Und ich habe noch nie was dazu gemacht. Aber, die scheinen echt viel Geld zu haben. Dafür wird sich das fast schon lohnen.
Naja, ich baue mal meine Mails mir dazu. Easy man. Ja, genau. Oh, ich habe Hunger so langsam.
Also, ich konnte ja bei Lieferando nur ankreuzen, Lieferung um 13.15 Uhr. Weil es das frühstmögliche war, wo man sich liefern lassen könnte.
Weil der Laden erst 12.30 Uhr aufmacht. Aber, der Laden ist von mir aus 200 Meter Luftlinie weg.
Frag mich jetzt nicht, warum ich da für einen Lieferservice bestelle. Weil der Laden 200 Meter weg ist. Vor allem auch über Lieferando. Ich hätte auch direkt anrufen können. Also der Laden ist 200 Meter Luftlinie weg. Ja Leute, so sieht es aus.
Erstmal einen schönen Lieferservice, der da mit dem Auto fährt, bestellt. Und deswegen rechne ich damit, dass es keine 45 Minuten braucht, mir das Zeug zu liefern.
Eigentlich richtig pepega, oder? Außerdem kann ich nicht streamen, während ich Essen holen gehe. Funktioniert nicht.
Wo ist die Musik vorbei? Nochmal eine Runde. Klar geht das. Nee, das geht nicht. Technisch mag das gehen, aber bei mir funktioniert das nicht.
Ich wollte übrigens gestern ein RL-Bild machen, aber kein Turm, damit ich richtig erkenne drauf. Ich wollte ein Call of Duty-Bild machen, weil die ja alle schreiben.
Irgendwo Bravo 6 Going Dark oder sowas. Das hat Twitter voll gewesen. Und da wollte ich mir eine Tüte über den Kopf ziehen, eine Papiertüte. Oh, oh es klingelt. Moment Leute.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
So Leute, da bin ich wieder und ich habe eine Tüte hier. Soll ich weiter streamen und essen? Oder soll ich streamen ausmachen?
Also ich habe einmal Tüte mit. Was ist das? Was ist das? Vielleicht die Pommes frites? Also.
Da ist Salat dabei. Salat. Monka S.
Ich habe keinen Platz auf meinem Schreibtisch. Salat mit so einer Sauce dabei. Das sind die Pommes frites und das ist Döner Pide.
Salat kann ich jetzt hier nehmen. Und den Döner muss ich mal kurz aufmachen.
Oder ist sogar schon mit Püttchen dabei. Salat, Essig, Alibi. Achja.
So, easy. Easy Futter, easy. Oh, ich brauche irgendwas zum Finger abputzen. Hab ich hier irgendwo noch?
Ja, guck mal. So Leute, jetzt erstmal hier erstmal die passende Musik anmachen.
Da. Oh. Ach, das ist heiß. Mach. Ultra heiß.
Du Schott. Alter.
Ja Leute, was gibt es bei euch so? Wenn überhaupt. Muss ich mal kurz eine Gabel holen.
Weil ansonsten hast du hier so ultra fettische Hände und wenn ich dann die Maus angreife, dann ist die Maus voll. Big Brain Satz, ich weiß.
So Leute, das war's für heute. Bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss.
Tschüss.
So. Ich habe gesehen, da ist auch noch so ein komischer Dip dabei.
Gut. Wir waren ja eben, wir waren ein bisschen dabei, Guitarprojekte zu gucken, oder? Das ist übrigens die Alternative zu der Sache, die ich da im Video erzählt habe, zum selbst VPN installieren.
Das ist auch quasi so ein Installer, der einem fertige, was auch immer man zu das Bild dann sagen soll, fertiges VPN Zeug bei einem entzählt. Aber man muss doch mal ganz ehrlich sagen, wirklich brauchen tut man das Ganze nicht.
Wir haben mal in irgendeinem Stream Viagard installiert, das war super einfach. Ich kann mich da mal richtig dran erinnern, aber vielleicht war jemand von euch in dem Stream dabei.
Das hat uns hier im Stream irgendwie eine Stunde gekostet.
Was kriegen wir denn sonst noch?
Ah, eine Route. Ein CLI-Routenplaner quasi. Okay, es gibt ein paar Sachen, die muss ich nicht unbedingt auf der Kommandozeile machen. Da gehört Routenplanung dabei.
Was haben wir sonst noch hier? Catch Two. C++ Header Only. Das ist was, da stehen die C++ Leute richtig drauf. Header Only, da finden die richtig geil. Am besten auch noch mit 20 Milliarden Makros, dass wenn einer den Sourcecode aufmacht, dass du nichts verstehst.
Okay, das Testing Framework von C++. Ich hoffe, das brauche ich nie. Ich brauche das mal Java.
So wirklich interessant sind die Trending Projects auf GitHub. Nix cooles dabei so richtig.
Ja, eigentlich wollte ich den Stream gerade schon ausmachen, Yanni, weil gerade mein Essen gekommen ist.
Aber Chat hat gesagt, ich soll einfach im Stream essen. Ah, das ist Today, stimmt.
Oh, das ist cool. Collection of 8000 publicly available IPTV-Channels. Oh, das ist cool. Das muss ich mir booken. Ich sage euch doch, ich habe es am Anfang gesagt, es gibt bei den GitHub-Projekten eigentlich immer mindestens ein Projekt, was man interessant findet.
Jedes Mal. Das heißt, es lohnt sich richtig, die Trending Projects zu gucken. Okay, was gibt es denn da in Germany? DE? Ja. DE. Ich habe doch gerade DE gesucht.
So viele IPTV-Channels haben wir kostenlos. Da ist bestimmt BibelTV. Oh, BibelTV. Endlich, endlich kann ich BibelTV auch ohne DVBC-Empfänger gucken.
Bester TV ist dann BibelTV HD auch noch. Nicht einfach nur BibelTV, sondern Begefeuer in 1080p. Wahnsinn, das habe ich gebraucht. Gibt es eigentlich auch KoranTV oder so?
Dann habe ich keine Ahnung. Die anderen haben dann irgendwie BibelTV. Die haben dann HD-Fegefeuer. Die anderen haben dann HD-Gebetsteppel oder so.
Für alle, wo der Rezept in der Wäsche ist. Das wiederholt sich. Das wiederholt sich nicht nur einfach so. Das wiederholt sich in Stunden.
Wir könnten allerdings auch was anderes anmachen. Ist BibelTV irgendein Running Gag? Nö. Ich mache mich nur immer ein bisschen los. Keine Ahnung warum. Wahrscheinlich wegen dem Name.
Ich mache jetzt mal Best Mario Music. Top 50 Mario Song of All Time.
Oh ja, das ist ja das Nice.
Perfekt.
Das Einzige, was ich mache, ist Atemzumar. Kommt, wollen wir ihn reinschieben. Moment. Ich glaube, der hat mir den falschen Pide-Tings geliefert.
Ich habe Pide bestellt mit Dönerfleisch und ich habe Pide mit Sucuk bekommen.
Allerdings, muss ich sagen, esse ich das auch gerne. Ich glaube, dass Pide Sucuk sogar teurer ist als Pide mit Dönerfleisch. Deswegen mache ich jetzt mal gar nichts.
Der Track Kling-Festal-Nivelle kann sein. Habe ich nicht gespielt.
Man muss sagen, es gibt mittlerweile eh ein paar Songs in neueren Spielen, die schon ein bisschen an den anderen Sachen orientieren.
Das war nicht das normale Battlefield 7, weil da war sein Handy wahrscheinlich nicht gut genug für, sondern von den Tönen her hatte ich das ein bisschen wie Battlefield angehört.
Ich habe nicht dran gedacht, ihn zu fragen, ob das Battlefield ist. Das ist Bomb-Omb-Field.
Das war eine richtig gute Idee, quasi zum Frühstück einen Döner zu bestellen. Es schmeckt richtig nice.
Das Problem ist, dass ich den Dipp nicht aufkriege. Ich war mit meiner Mutter in der Notaufnahme. Gestern um 23.30 Uhr haben die Notarzt gerufen und ich bin heute Morgen erst um 5.30 Uhr heimgekommen.
Ich fahre da auch nachher noch mal hin. Als ich jetzt in Ruhe was esse, packe ich ein paar Sachen ein, fahre ich da hin und morgen wird da nichts sein. Am Montag kann sie dann wieder heim.
Alles gut ausgegangen. Es war wohl auch nichts wirklich Ernstes. Wie kriege ich diesen Dipp auf, ohne dass ich die ganze Zeit mit den Fingern schmier.
So, jetzt ist Level Dipp Opening. Kennt von euch allen nur, das Blumen C zu lernen. Ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Aber, was du machen kannst ist, mal gucken ob es was bei Galileo Open Book gibt.
Mal gucken ob es was für C gibt.
Den mag ich nicht. Mario 2 ist kein richtiges Mario.
Jawoll.
Wobei, wobei, wenn du Fiori draufspringst, macht sie er.
Und Zunge ist in Mario, wollt ihr er. Okay, was auch immer.
Geht dir das Feature mit den Namen auf den Sack, wenn du über Tab hoppst? Nö. Das ist über... Hä? Wo ist es denn?
Äh, ich glaube, kann es sein, dass mein Chromium nicht aktuell ist?
Moment, ich glaube mein Chromium ist nicht aktuell.
Aktualisier mal schnell.
Ah ja.
Ich kann es jetzt nicht installieren, weil dann geht der Browser zu.
Ach, das ist doch gar nicht so klein.
Was verwendet ihr denn jetzt gerade? OpenVPN oder...
Und dann kannst du immer noch das Top machen auf Windows.
Ich muss echt sagen Leute, das mit dem Döner bestellen war eine super Idee.
Das Döner, das ich bestellt habe, schmeckt echt gut.
Ja, also Prime 160 wird es, also wenn du VPN machen willst, dann WireGuard ist auf jeden Fall eine sinnvolle Alternative.
Die ist nämlich gespendet und ist halt relativ neu, muss man sagen.
Ist nicht so getestet und stabil vielleicht oder sicher, überprüft sicher wie andere.
Aber ich meine, ich benutze es auch.
Ihr könnt euch auch irgendeinen Windows Terminal Server machen oder so.
Da habe ich aber überhaupt keine Erfahrung mit.
Ist das ein riesen Unterschied zu VPN in der Fritzbox?
Ich glaube, das VPN von der Fritzbox ist IPsec, oder?
Oder ist das auch ein VPN? Weißt du das hier, Mann?
Dann ist es schon ein ganz schöner Unterschied.
IPsec ist ja eher so das Business-VPN.
Außerdem liegt das, also ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen, dass das daran liegt, dass die VPN Technik sagen würde, dass bei euch so langsam ist.
Ist euer Upload vielleicht kacke?
Könnte ja auch sein.
Prime 106, das kann daran liegen. Also an der VPN Technik wird das nicht liegen. IPsec funktioniert wunderbar, VPN funktioniert wunderbar, Feuerrad funktioniert wunderbar.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, je nachdem worauf das läuft, dass die Hardware einfach zu schwach ist.
Weil VPN, auch schon, wenn du ein bisschen Traffic machst, auch schon recht gut CPU, vor allem halt auf schwachbrüstigen Geräten.
Wenn du was hast mit ein bisschen Leistung, ist das kein Problem.
Wir haben mehrere Windows 2008 Windows Server, denkt das darüber noch?
Ist das PPTP vielleicht noch? Das ist uralt und sollte eigentlich gar nicht mehr verwendet werden.
Mehr kann ich dir nicht zu sagen, weil das kann immer alles sein.
Sonst kann man jetzt Remote sehr schlecht diagnostizieren.
Mario Land auf Gameboy habe ich auch super viel, also wirklich extrem viel gespielt, weil ich hatte bloß zwei Spiele auf Gameboy am Anfang.
Ich hatte Tetris und ich hatte Mario Land und Mario Land war mein absolutes Hassspiel, weil das für mich damals unglaublich schwer gewesen ist.
Oder wahrscheinlich auch wirklich schwer war.
Und auch vom Designer finde ich nicht schön.
Mario Land dieses Raumschiff Levels, so ein Kack, Alter.
Hast du auch nie geschafft? Ja, ich habe es nie durchgespielt.
Das ist mein meistgehasstes Mario Game.
Dabei muss man sagen, dass was danach kam, dieses Secret Coins oder irgendwie so, das war eigentlich ganz cool.
Kein Captain Freistell, nee.
Ich esse jetzt meinen Döner, dann packe ich ein paar Sachen ein, muss das Karten rausfahren, aber ich sage nicht für mich.
Vielleicht machen wir dann, wenn ich wieder da bin heute Abend, das Wetter nicht so lange bleiben.
Frühstück, ja, viele Döner und ein paar Pommes frites dabei, bestes Frühstück.
Oh, das ist ein nice Song.
Der Captain Freistell von MW ist sehr hoch. Ich sage ja, der Freistell ist heiß.
Ja, ich kenne das mit dem, ich kenne die Storm Bubbles.
Ich habe da bei mir auf dem anderen Account einen aktuelleren Browser.
Ich finde es gar nicht so wild, ehrlich gesagt.
Es hat mich jetzt bis jetzt nicht gestört, das heißt nicht, dass es mich in Zukunft nicht stört.
Beste Frühstück, viele Döner und Pommes frites.
Und theoretisch habe ich drüben noch einen Salat stehen, aber den habe ich jetzt erstmal ausgeklammert.
Weil er braucht Salate.
Dann kommen die 4K Streams.
Wenn, dann richtig, sobald 4K 144, ne, ne, ne, trust me.
Sobald 4K 240 als möglich ist, dann gibt es 4K Streams.
Macht keine halben Sachen. Wenn schon, dann gleich 4K 240.
Ah, Delphino Blast, auch nice, nice Musik.
Wie viel kostet ein Döner bei dir?
Also ich habe jetzt für ein Piede Döner, also quasi so ein...
Prinzip ist es ein bisschen wieder klar.
Für so ein Ding, für so ein Ding, plus kleiner Salat, plus kleiner Pommes frites habe ich, glaube 10 Euro oder 9 Euro,
inklusive Lieferungen wohlgemerkt.
Nach soll ich gleich, was ich bezahlt habe.
Einfach nach.
Die Bezahlung am Takeaway, 10 Euro, was ich bezahlt.
In US Dollar.
Hä?
Warum bezahle ich meine Lieferando Bestellung beim Dönerladen 200 Meter von mir weg in US Dollar?
Das ist big brainer.
Big brainer.
Ein Veggie Burger.
Na gut, hat jeder so seins.
Hara Bulix, trockenes Brot.
Du kannst aber auch nicht schlecht werden. Davon kann man auch kein Dünnsches kriegen.
Da geht ja nichts dran.
Wie fandest du MW bisher?
Die Story hat viel verschenktes Potential.
Ich finde die Idee ganz cool, wie sie es gemacht haben, aber da hätte man mehr draus machen können.
Außerdem, sagt mal Leute, die die gestern dabei waren.
Die haben ja großartig Captain Price angekündigt.
Captain Price hat so gut wie keine Rolle in der Kampagne bisher.
Das ist einfach nur manchmal da.
OBS Einstellungen sind wieder gefixt.
Das Problem an OBS Einstellungen war die zwei Sachen.
Profile Main, Keyframe Intervall 2.
Das tut wieder alles.
Ja Hara Bulix, ich finde auch, es geht in die richtige Richtung.
An sich haben sie da schon viel Potential verschwindet.
Bis jetzt, was ich cool finde, dass in der MW Kampagne man die unterschiedlichen Spielcharaktere auch mal zusammen in der Mission hat.
Also den Alex Typ, den man spielt, dass man den dann auch zusammen hat, wenn man Keil spielen soll im Team.
Sind die Schritte der Team jetzt immer noch so laut? Keine Ahnung.
Elevencore, findest du?
Vielleicht ein bisschen.
Wie fandest du die Mission als kleines Mädchen?
Der russische Soldat war übelst dämlich.
Es war auch eine Mission, wo sie echt viel Potential haben liegen lassen.
Das ist übrigens da, wo wir gestern auch aufgehört haben.
Den russischen Soldaten am Anfang, den konntest du einfach Wall klitschen.
Also merkt euch Leute, wenn ihr mal klein seid und habt russische Soldaten bei euch im Haus,
dann einfach immer um die Ecke von der Mauer gucken, um die andere Ecke von der Mauer gucken
und dann wieder um die Ecke von der Mauer gucken und dann weiß er nicht, wo ihr seid.
Hast du eigentlich das Lino Cooney Remastered? Nee.
Ist das also Remastered? Ich dachte, es gibt einen zweiten Teil.
Der irgendwie nicht mehr von den originalen Pizzas ist oder wie war das?
Oh Leute, der Döner ist echt sehr nass.
Was ist das denn? Kein Döner, das ist eigentlich eher eine Pizza.
Kann man sich nicht beschweren.
Wahrscheinlich war ich auch der erste, der heute das Essen gemacht hat.
Weil ich hab ja um 11 schon vorbestellt für 12.30 Uhr auf 13.15 Uhr.
Wahrscheinlich wurde die Kochplatte heute mit meinem Essen eingeweiht.
Das ist einer meiner absoluten Lieblings Mario Tracks hier. Battle Rock Galaxy.
Generell hat Mario Galaxy mit dem besten Soundtrack, finde ich.
Und wie war es im Krankenhaus? Naja, zum größten Teil rumgesetzt halt.
Ich hab Essen pre-ordert, richtig.
Ich weiß, ich sag ja immer niemals vorbestellen,
aber bei Döner oder beim Mittagessen kann man ja mal eine Ausnahme machen.
Da kriegt man dann aber auch keine Lootboxen verkauft.
Max gibt es eine gute Anleitung zum Thema Webseiten erstellen.
Was ist Jimdo?
Eine CMS? Hab ich schon nie gehört.
Das sind leider nichts für mich, da ich einige Features einbauen möchte,
was die nicht unterstützen.
Was ist Jimdo?
Ich weiß es echt nicht. Ist das ein Hausdingerbieter?
Ach, das ist so eine Website-Bilder-Seite.
Ja, das ist es.
Zack, Alter.
Huge Sack.
Ihr fahrt Jimdo.
Also was ich dir empfehlen würde ist, entweder, wenn du gar keinen Plan hast,
also du hast eigentlich zwei Möglichkeiten, entweder du hast keinen Plan
und ein bisschen Geld, dann lass dir eine Website erstellen.
Oder aber, du hast keinen Plan und kein Geld, dann installier dir irgendeinen CMS
auf einem Hausdingerbieter, WordPress oder so.
Und mach damit deine Website.
Und wenn du ein bisschen Plan hast und dich damit beschäftigen willst,
dann würd ich sagen, kannst du auch eine einfache Website relativ selber bauen.
Wenn es jetzt natürlich ein Webshop werden soll, den würd ich nicht setzten.
Da gibt's genug fertige.
Kennst du nicht die Cringe Ads von denen? Nee.
Wollen wir mal gucken.
Jimdo.
Cringe Ads.
Jimdo-TVs.
Fuck, die sind Schweizer.
Ist das schlimm.
Ich kann mir das nicht angucken, das tut dir echt weh.
Die Werbung tut mir echt schon weh, wenn ich das sehe.
Also denen würd ich nicht gehen.
Also wie gesagt, die Geschichte mit WordPress ist wahrscheinlich keine schlechte Variante.
Wenn du dich nicht auskennst, auch keine Zeit hast oder dich damit groß beschäftigen willst,
installier dir irgendeinen CMS.
Es muss nicht WordPress sein, WordPress ist halt das Verbreitetste.
Neben einem halbwegs gutes WordPress-Template kannst du dir entweder auf GitHub suchen oder aber
kaufst dir eins für ein paar Euro, wie gut es ist.
Wenn das Essen dann an Day 1 schon voller Bugs ist, wird es später nicht besser.
Das stimmt.
Und man kann vor allem für Mittagessen keinen Day Zero Patch nachreichen.
Wieso ist das Chrom-Logo bei dir eigentlich genau?
Weil es Chromium ist anstatt Chrom.
Aber Chrom hab ich auch drauf.
Max, du hast in einem Video mal kurz Passwort-Manager erwähnt.
Was verwendest du?
Ich meine, Key Pass.
Ja gut, den machst du jetzt nicht auf.
Key Pass.
Du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du.
Moin, Max.
Wie werde ich die Hass.io Docker-Container los?
Brauche ich ein bisschen mehr Kontext, dass ich verstehe, was du genau machen willst?
Einfach löschen.
Das muss man ein bisschen genauer erklären.
Max, hast du das mitbekommen?
Ist der Greetings Id
kein Video oder Blödsinn?
Ja.
Ja, Aquarius, hat dir das jetzt bisschen was geholfen?
Also ich würde, ich würde WordPress mit ordentlichen Template.
Achso, ah, ich sehs gerade.
Im Webshop soll es nicht werden, kann man bei WordPress ein dynamisch verändernde Rangliste
erstellen, die sich mit Abstimmung automatisch verändert.
Du kannst, ich hab keine Ahnung, aber du kannst den WordPress wahrscheinlich so gut
wie alles machen.
Für WordPress ist das größte CMS, was es so gibt und dafür gibt es Gott und die Welt
an Plugins.
Bestimmt geht das irgendwie, aber da kann ich jetzt nicht genau sagen wie.
Esmongol hat Trump gewählt, da kann jeder wählen was er will.
Ich sag ja auch nicht, dass ich die Tierschutzpartei wähle, jeder machen was er will.
Esmongol hat Trump gewählt, da kann jeder wählen was er will, jeder machen was er will.
Esmongol hat Trump gewählt, oder j
Betriebssystem, was für nichts anderes da ist, als Hass.io laufen zu lassen.
Dann musst du einfach auf die SD-Karte ein neues Raspbian flashen, um gut ist.
Oder hast du den normalen Linux-Installer genommen, der dein normales Raspbian zu einem
Hass.io umbastelt?
Das ist jetzt die Frage.
Ah, und der Raspbian hast du das gemacht.
Dann musst du, du musst glaube ich erst mal userbin, user, musst mal userbin Hass.io
oder irgendwie so gucken.
Das musst du glaube ich, würde ich mal moveen.
Und das wichtigste ist, du musst diesen Supervisor ausschalten, sonst startet er die Container
immer wieder neu.
Habt ihr das unter Raspbian?
Hass.io ist aber echt gut.
Doch, doch, du hast das gemacht, du hast das hier gemacht, guck.
Das hast du gemacht, das da hast du gemacht, das da hast du gemacht, ne?
Ach, siehste?
Wie ich das schon allein an der Beschreibung gehört hab.
Das mach ich auch immer so, köln nach fest, genau.
Das ist halt normalerweise nicht zu empfehlen, aber in dem Fall, ich weiß, was es in Solar
Script macht, ne?
Also, ich hab das noch nie gemacht, muss ich dir ehrlich sagen, aber ich glaube du
musst user, user share, userbin, user share oder so, glaube ich, die haben da ein eigenes
Verzeichnis, wo die ganze Konfig von dem Geschütz rumliegt.
Das musst du wegschmeißen und du musst diesen Supervisor Container ausschalten.
Da musst du mal googeln, die haben so einen Master Container installiert, der alle anderen
Container startet.
Den musst du deaktivieren, deinstallieren und danach machst du einfach docker stop,
docker rm, die anderen docker Container.
So, so würde ich das wahrscheinlich probieren, ich hab selbst noch nie deinstalliert, ehrlich
gesagt.
Aber ich glaube, ein einfaches deinstall Script gibt's nicht.
Hast du mal googelt gesucht?
Double Dash, es ist, ehrlich gesagt, auch wenn es nicht so das beliebte Mario Kart ist,
aber mein persönliches Lieblings Mario Kart.
Bestes Glitzscreen mit dem Razor gemacht.
Genau, wie ich gesagt hab.
Mario Kart Wii fand ich auch ganz nice, vor allem mit den Motorrädern, das fand ich
auch was neues.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich fand das letzte Mario Kart auf der, kam ja auf der Wii U noch raus
und das haben sie jetzt ja quasi repackaged für die Switch, das fand ich persönlich
jetzt gar nicht so toll.
Hast du den Cromart mit dem Büro gesehen?
Ach hier, Max, was hältst du von Büro-Controlls für alle zukünftigen Shooter, ob bloß nicht,
rumgefoltert brauch ich nicht, Analog-Sticks wären überhaupt beste.
Ich mein, für manche Sachen ist das ganz cool, aber bitte nicht auf Teufel-Kommerhaus
einbauen.
Ich mein, für manche Sachen ist das mit Sicherheit cool, für Ace Combat oder sowas,
ich mein, für manche Sachen ist das mit Sicherheit cool, für Ace Combat oder sowas,
Wenn man es nicht einfach einbaut in die Games nur um es einzubauen, sondern halt sinnvoll machen.
Gyros, nee. Gyro oder Piededöner, eins von beiden kannst du dir auch suchen. Aber Gyros haben wir gar nicht.
Monka Griechenland.
Das Touchpad von DualShock ist genauso körperlich. Kann ich ehrlich gesagt nicht beurteilen.
Ich hab auf der PS4 damit so gut wie nie was gemacht.
Das sind die Credits. Ich wollte gerade sagen, die Musik kommt mir noch bekannt vor.
Der Steam Controller kriegt das gut hin.
Ich glaube, ich hatte mal von Felix an der Hand. Hatte der Steam Controller keine Analog-Sticks und nur Touch.
Also nur Touch glaube ich ist keine gute Idee. Vor allem nicht zum Laufen. Zum Aim zusätzlich ist wahrscheinlich nicht wert.
Aber generell muss man sagen, Movement mit Touch ist kacke.
Schaut euch mal Call of Duty Mobile an, wie müllig sich das steuert, wenn man sich die Videos dazu anguckt.
Ich sag euch ehrlich, ich glaube ich hab noch nie so lang dummer Mittagessen gebraucht wie heute.
Ich hab jetzt eine Stunde Mittag gegessen und bin noch nicht mal fertig. Aber eigentlich ist das gesund, wenn man langsam futtert.
Was er futtert? Viele Döner mit Pommes frites.
Und theoretisch Salat, aber den hab ich drüben hingestellt, den esse ich nicht.
Der Steam Controller ist nicht so interessierbar. Hab ich schon nicht mehr.
Was ich cool finde, was ich damals mit dem Wii Controller gemacht hab am PC.
Dass du im Endeffekt die Wii Mode besser am PC verwenden konntest als an der Wii.
Weil ich
Was ist denn das? Warte mal.
Oh, wenn ich, wenn ich hier irgendwie was mit, mit, mit Brit und so höre, da muss ich immer an Total Biscuit denken, ja.
Der hieß ja auch so ähnlich. Die hat es echt hart getroffen, der Typ war fast genauso alt wie ich. Wir waren fast gleich alt.
Der hieß ja auch so ähnlich, die hat es echt hart getroffen, alter der Typ war fast genauso alt wie ich, wir waren fast gleich alt.
Erst ist vor ein paar Jahren Internethalt gestorben, das war ja einer der ersten deutschen Overwatch Pros, der war eine ganze Ecke jünger als ich, dann ist TotalBiscuit gestorben, der war ziemlich genauso alt wie ich und letztens ist da noch irgendeiner gestorben.
Wo ich auch wieder gedacht habe, what the fuck, InControl, InControl, genau, der war auch ein paar Jahre jünger als ich.
InControl meine ich, richtig krass wie die Leute die Löffel abgeben, die teilweise jünger sind oder genauso alt sind wie ich.
Fuck, richtig viel Batman.
Ok, gucken wir uns das mal kurz an.
Ich bin hier mit einem neuen Video, ich versuche etwas seltsames zu machen.
Ich hatte nur noch nie genug FPS-Games in meinem Leben, wir hatten PUBG, das ging sehr gut.
Wir hatten Fortnite und ich meine, ich will Fortnite nicht spielen, ich will nicht ein Spiel spielen, in dem ein Kind besser Reflexes hat als ich, also sie werden immer 9 x 10 gewinnen.
Also stelle ich mir tatsächlich den Fortnite-Spieler vor.
Erst mal schöne Stop-Fotos.
Ah, ich muss stoppen, dass man mich versteht, ok.
Gut, macht nichts, sonst kann ich jetzt ja essen.
69, das war klar.
Und da ist ein Ghost dabei.
Aber die Emulator-Geschichte sack, habe ich gehört.
Ok.
Und ich habe gelesen, man kann Call of Duty Mobile auf dem PC spielen mit Android-Emulator, aber man kommt in Lobbys nur mit Emulator-Spielern und Bots.
Also es lohnt sich eigentlich überhaupt nicht, mal gucken wie er das macht.
Natürlich.
Das ist jetzt ein Mobile-Game, da ist das ja noch irgendwie, sagen wir mal, es ist gang und gäbe, ob es ok ist, was anderes, aber da ist das noch irgendwie nachvollziehbar.
Aber guckt euch mal Black Ops 4 an und CoD Mobile, so ein großer Unterschied ist da gar nicht dazwischen, das eine ist ein Vollpreis-Spiel und das andere ist ein F2P-Mobile-Game.
War eine lange Zeit in einem CoD Mobile-Klan, wie kann es so eine lange Zeit in einem CoD Mobile-Klan gewesen sein, wenn es das Game erst seit 3 Wochen oder so gibt?
Oder gibt es das schon länger?
Das sieht tatsächlich aus wie Fortnite-Skin, hat er recht.
Ja gut, jetzt reg dich mal nicht auf, das ist Mobile-Crap, also er hat schon recht, aber mich über Mobile-Pay2Win und Mobile-Abzocker aufzuregen, das habe ich schon aufgegeben.
Die Leute wollen das auf Mobile so.
Aber das sind zwei Stücke Kiel.
Ah fuck.
Ja, Alter, leg mal los.
Ich habe schon ein Like gegeben, mein Gott.
Lasst uns direkt in diese Freude fangen, als wir ein Multiplayer-Game starten.
Ja, aber wenn ihr Immolator spielt, kommt ihr gegen Bots.
Ich denke, ich bin mal gespannt, ob das echt Bots sind.
Es sieht doch schon wie die laufen, dass das Bots sind.
Ich meine, noch schlimmer, es sind Mobile-Bots, das ist noch eine Runde schlimmer.
Wir haben echte Spielernamen zum Schein, aber es sind Bots.
Ich meine, eigentlich ist es taktisch gar nicht so schlecht, die Leute gegen Bots zu matchen, dass die denken, Alter, ich bin der krasseste Aune ever und dann auch schön Geld ausgeben für.
Mario Kart Tour hat ja angeblich auch keine echten Mitspieler.
Das ist ja gut.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Wir müssen uns das Video nicht weiter angucken.
Macht mehr Spaß als COD auf der Konsole?
Ja, aber was macht auf der Konsole Spaß?
Laut die Mario Musiker.
Es gibt genug Spiele, die auf der Konsole Spaß machen.
Ich wollte nur mal mein PC Master Race Bildchen einblenden können.
Also die Outer Worlds angesehen.
Ja, aber nicht gekauft, aber ich kaufe es mir noch.
Ich bin echt gespannt drauf.
Fuck, ich schlug auf.
Gut, Leute, ich habe viel länger gestreamt als ich wollte.
Muss jetzt meine Mutter mal anrufen und fragen, was ich ihr noch ins Krankenhaus bringen soll.
Und dann fahre ich ins Krankenhaus und bin wahrscheinlich nachher irgendwann wieder da.
Und vielleicht ein gescheites Essen.
Das kann nicht so schlecht sein.
Ich habe mir das mal angeguckt.
Also ich habe Bewertungen geguckt.
Aber ich frage sie mal, ich frage sie mal.
Und mal gucken, vielleicht spielen wir, wie gesagt, ich habe jetzt ja eh hier.
Zwei Tage bin ich jetzt hier allein am Start.
Da wird auch keiner irgendwie, dass man den Fernseher fixt oder so.
Also, den haben wir hier.
Abonniert Stufe eins.
Vier Monate.
Dankeschön.
Nice.
Gute und bessere.
Ja, danke.
Ich bin da zuversichtlich.
Ging ja auch schon wieder besser.
Also Leute, wir sehen uns.
Das war jetzt eigentlich eher Mittagessen stream, oder?
Wir haben ein bisschen geschwätzt, dann gab es Mittagessen.
Und ich habe jetzt eine Stunde 15 Minuten gegessen im Stream.
0W.
Gibt es irgendjemanden, den man hosten kann?
Schau mal schnell, wen haben wir hier, den man hosten kann?
Nix.
Der Chat ist ja...
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr was geschrieben habt, ich habe es nicht gesehen.
Aber Peetspeed braucht man raus nicht.
Da hat wahrscheinlich wieder 3000, 4000 Zuschauer.
Ich hoste ganz gerne Leute.
Erstens, die ich selber gucke und die halt noch kleiner sind.
Also Leute, dann sehen wir uns eventuell heute Abend.
Oder wahrscheinlich sogar heute Abend.
Oder vielleicht sogar schon vor Abend, weil ich fahre da jetzt hin, bringe das Zeug hin.
Und dann fahre ich wieder heim, aber es bringt nichts, wenn ich da 4 Stunden im Krankenhaus rumsehe.
Also macht's gut.
Bis später.
T.O.